Alice:呆会儿可以吃小甜品了
Alice: We'll have some desserts later.
其他人：这地方为什么叫 佑佑的院子老板叫佑佑吗
Others: Why is this place called Youyou's Yard? Is the owner named Youyou?
Alice: 对 这个就是这个这个
Alice: Yes, it's this, this.
Alice: 这个房间
Alice: This room.
Alice: 他们就是租的时候这个的名字
Alice: They used this name when they rented it.
其他人：兄弟们给我来点水我有点
Others: Guys, can I get some water? I'm a bit...
Alice: 你想喝我的水吧
Alice: You want to drink my water, right?
Alice:这不知道谁的 你就直接用我的吧
Alice: I don't know whose this is, just use mine.
其他人：这个有两层吗
Others: Does this have two floors?
Alice:是的 其实三层
Alice: Yes, actually three floors.
Alice: 第三层不能上
Alice: The third floor is off-limits.
Alice:切
Alice: Tsk.
其他人：这水怎么一股茶味
Others: Why does this water taste like tea?
其他人：因为泡太久茶了
Others: Because the tea has been steeped for too long.
其他人：变味了哈哈
Others: It's gone bad, haha.
Alice:怎么了请你免费喝茶不好吗
Alice: What's wrong? Isn't it nice to have free tea?
其他人：是那种老板水杯里面的茶
Others: It's that kind of tea from the boss's cup.
其他人：多年的茶
Others: Years-old tea.
Alice:多年的茶垢
Alice: Years-old tea stains.
Alice:怎么呢
Alice: What's up?
Alice:啊哈哈哈
Alice: Ahahaha.
其他人：看对对角
Others: Look at the diagonal.
其他人：对角对角
Others: The diagonal, the diagonal.
其他人： 怎么有一块翻白的那个哈哈
Others: Why is there a white spot flipping over, haha.
Alice: 我真服了
Alice: I'm really impressed.
其他人：随时随地发现新科技
Others: Discovering new technology anytime, anywhere.
Alice: 行了刘婷别找了
Alice: Alright Liu Ting, stop searching.
Alice: 足够赎我了
Alice: It's enough to redeem me.
Alice: 给别的嘉宾留一点
Alice: Leave some for other guests.
Alice: 大家还没到齐
Alice: Not everyone is here yet.
Tasha: 还有几个人
Tasha: How many more people?
Alice: 呃我也不知道
Alice: Uh, I don't know either.
Alice: 刘婷你你你上瘾了是吧
Alice: Liu Ting, you're addicted, aren't you?
Alice: 这个像不像
Alice: Does this look like...
Alice: 如果把他想象成
Alice: If you imagine it as...
Alice: 如果把他想象成你
Alice: 我到是抓挺有劲
其他人：啊YOU
Others: Ah, YOU.
Alice:我有
Alice: I have it.
Alice: 你可以用我的充这个
Alice: You can use my charger for this.
Alice: 这个充电宝上有那个那个啥连的线
Alice: This power bank has that, that connecting wire.
Alice: 这呢
Alice: Here it is.
Alice: 对
Alice: Right.
Alice: 这个眼镜是要充着电用哎
Alice: These glasses need to be charged to use.
Alice: 要不你搁那充吧
Alice: How about you charge it over there?
Alice: 你看那底下那不
Alice: Look under there, isn't it?
Alice: 哎呀这缺的就是充电宝
Alice: Oh, we just need a power bank.
Alice: 你瞅见了吗
Alice: Did you see it?
Alice: 这不充电宝是啥呀
Alice: Isn't that a power bank?
Alice: 充上呗
Alice: Go ahead and charge it.
Alice: 我怎么就一个了呢
Alice: Why do I only have one?
Alice: 但是好像是头不太对
Alice: But the head doesn't seem right.
其他人：没有没有苹果的线是吗
Others: There's no Apple cable, right?
Alice: 那你用我这个吧
Alice: Then use mine.
Alice:不是不是
Alice: No, no.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 你待会待会我拿我的给你充吧
Alice: Wait a bit, I'll use mine to charge it for you.
Alice: 我那个在屋里
Alice: Mine is in the room.
Alice: 那个线呢
Alice: Where's the cable?
Alice: 你不累吗
Alice: Aren't you tired?
Alice: 你坐那马上骑会呗
Alice: Sit down and rest for a bit.
Alice: 怎么了你别又瞅见了啊
Alice: What's wrong? Don't look again.
Alice:可以
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this.
Shure:  你快找去让
Shure: Quickly find it.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  它这个分辨率就就会这个样子
Shure: The resolution will look like this.
Shure:  不要瞎说大实话好吗
Shure: Don't speak the hard truth.
Alice: 那倒不是
Alice: Not really.
Alice: 大部分点外卖
Alice: Mostly ordering takeout.
Alice: 然后有时候做火锅烧烤之类的
Alice: Sometimes we do hotpot or BBQ.
Alice: 就录一下那个活动
Alice: We just record those activities.
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Alice: 然后明天就收尾
Alice: Then we'll wrap it up tomorrow.
其他人：我可以把最难的那个告诉你
Others: I can tell you where the hardest one is.
其他人：最难那个藏在你装饰的门把手
Others: The hardest one is hidden in your decorated doorknob.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahaha.
其他人：不我就藏了一个最难的
Others: No, I just hid the hardest one.
其他人：没有只有一个
Others: No, there's only one.
Alice:  哎 闭住
Alice: Hey, quiet.
其他人：猫
Others: Cat.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
其他人：要确认他们接的就可以是吗
Others: Just confirm that they connected, right?
其他人：得确认他们还有多少电
Others: Need to check how much battery they have left.
其他人：你觉得多少是一个警界线
Others: How much do you think is the threshold?
Alice: 都是每人一个房间
Alice: Everyone has their own room.
其他人：要不要贴这个眼睛上
Others: Should we stick this on our eyes?
Alice: 来吧
Alice: Go ahead.
其他人：不随身带那么猎奇的东西
Others: Don't carry such weird stuff around.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This.
Alice: 这个不会是有什么专门的用处吧
Alice: Does this have a special use?
Alice: 这是谁的
Alice: 这个是有什么专门的用处吗
Alice: Does this have a special use?
Alice: 就可以随便贴着玩是吧
Alice: Or can we just stick it for fun?
Alice: 嗯来吧
Alice: Yeah, go ahead.
Alice: 一人一个
Alice: One for each.
其他人：你买到回家的票了吗
Others: Did you get a ticket to go home?
Alice: 没不回去了
Alice: No, I'm not going back.
其他人：那你这5天干什么
Others: What are you going to do for these 5 days?
Alice: 再说吧
Alice: We'll see.
Alice:想到一天是一天
Alice: Taking it one day at a time.
其他人：想着买了去的票还能买回来的票
Others: Thinking you can buy a return ticket after buying a ticket to go.
Shure:  假币
Shure: Fake money.
Alice: 没关系在哪都一样
Alice: It doesn't matter, it's the same everywhere.
Alice: 五一爆炸人多
Alice: May Day is too crowded.
Alice: 哎要不我去你家玩吧刘婷
Alice: Hey, how about I visit your place, Liu Ting?
其他人：他要别的价钱我跟你说
Others: He'll charge you a different price, I'm telling you.
Alice: 你不应该邀请我一下吗
Alice: Shouldn't you invite me?
Alice: 你现在可以发出邀请
Alice: You can invite me now.
Jake: 在哪充电了
Jake: Where did you charge it?
其他人: 换掉我放你放你
Others: Change it, let me, let me.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 我去你家玩了
Alice: I'm going to your place.
Alice: 刘婷给我准备好床
Alice: Liu Ting, prepare a bed for me.
Alice: 我要我要
Alice: I want, I want.
Alice: 新的拖鞋 床单被罩
Alice: New slippers, bed sheets, and quilt cover.
Alice: 可以用你的
Alice: I can use yours.
Alice: 床也要躺你的
Alice: I even want to lie on your bed.
其他人：照你这个频率每周都出去逛个景点估计北京市 早就让你逛完了
Others: At the rate you visit a tourist spot every week, you'd have toured all of Beijing by now.
Alice: 我已经逛完了差不多
Alice: I've almost finished touring.
Alice: 完蛋了差你家没去了
Alice: The only place I haven't been is your home.
Alice: 你能不能给我唱一首北京欢迎你
Alice: Can you sing "Beijing Welcomes You" for me?
Alice: 就是我家大门常打开
Alice: 我都不知道你家门在哪开
Alice: I don't even know where your door opens.
其他人：: 不知道就好
Shure:  不要一脸嫌弃的眼神看着我
Shure: Don’t look at me with that disgusted expression.
Alice: 你真的不邀请我去你家玩吗
Alice: Are you really not inviting me to your place?
其他人：你这邀请你去我家玩儿不给我增添家务吗
Others: If I invite you to my place, won’t that just add to my chores?
Alice: 对呀又可以
Alice: Yeah, but it’s okay.
Alice: 都可以给你
Alice: It’s all fine.
Alice: 可以让你多运动
Alice: It can help you get more exercise.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
其他人：YOU不给自己找事儿干吗
Others: Aren’t you just looking for trouble for yourself?
Alice:大馋丫头
Alice: You greedy girl.
Alice: 是不是我的呀
Alice: Is this mine?
Alice: 啊啊啊
Alice: Ahhh.
Alice: 没事不是我的
Alice: Never mind, it’s not mine.
Alice: 那个看看见好像没有人用哎
Alice: It looks like no one is using it.
Alice: 这个这个
Alice: This one, this one.
Alice: 啊啊那也是
Alice: Ah, yes, that too.
Alice: 要不你玩那个拼图吧
Alice: How about you play with the puzzle?
其他人： 这个看起来没有很
Alice: 我看你在这挺没事干的
Alice: You seem pretty bored here.
其他人：我的手机充着电呢
Others: My phone is charging.
Alice: OK了等一下
Alice: Okay, just wait a bit.
Alice:麻薯
Alice: Mochi.
Alice: 你这特别像一个什么神仙下凡
Alice: You look just like some deity descending to earth.
Alice: 你这装扮
Alice: Your outfit.
Alice: 你这大赤耳朵
Alice: Those big red ears.
Alice: 有福之相
Alice: You look blessed.
Alice:你这给我都粘进去了
Alice: You got it all stuck on me.
Alice: 那不是你自己粘的吗
Alice: Didn’t you stick it yourself?
Alice: 你放什么屁呢
Alice: What nonsense are you talking?
Alice: 那不你自己粘的吗
Alice: Didn’t you stick it yourself?
Alice: 我在房间里
Alice: I’m in the room.
Alice: 你耳朵是你自己粘的呀你忘了
Alice: You stuck your own ears, remember?
其他人：你不粘了吗
Others: Didn’t you stick it?
Alice: 我没给你粘
Alice: I didn’t stick it for you.
Alice: 你自己粘的
Alice: You stuck it yourself.
Alice: 你怎么乱污蔑人呢你这人
Alice: Why are you falsely accusing people?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Tasha: 你挤吧
Tasha: You squeeze it.
Tasha: 挤一个小团子小团子的出来
Tasha: Squeeze out a little ball, a little ball.
Alice: 挤一个爱心型的
Alice: Squeeze out a heart shape.
Alice: 哈哈哈送给刘婷哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha, this is for Liu Ting, hahaha.
其他人：没人管管她吗
Others: Isn't anyone going to stop her?
Tasha: 不在也不在我房间哎
Tasha: It's not in my room either, geez.
其他人：咱俩这块怎么吃呢
Others: How are we supposed to eat this?
Tasha: 这样子吧
Tasha: Just like this.
Alice: 我能团成这样吧
Alice: Can I roll it like this?
其他人：因为我没有打火机
Others: Because I don't have a lighter.
Tasha: 就这样子放那
Tasha: Just leave it there.
Tasha: 不用你一直挤就行了
Tasha: You don't need to keep squeezing it.
Alice: 可是我觉得我想给他团的圆圆的
Alice: But I want to make it really round.
Lucia: 他那个打火机好像好像棉芯有点用完了
Lucia: His lighter seems to be running out of wick.
Alice: 你往粉的地方放
Alice: Put it where the powder is.
Tasha: 不然我拿不下来
Tasha: Or else I can't take it off.
其他人：: 这个肯定不行这个肯定不行
其他人：看看你干的好事儿这是这叫什么来着
Others: Look at what you did, what do you call this?
Lucia: 那个空调遥控器我就没怎么见过
Lucia: I haven't really seen that AC remote before.
其他人：麻薯
Others: Mochi.
其他人：就是那个粉
Others: Yeah, that powder.
Alice: 黄豆粉
Alice: Soybean flour.
Tasha: 太小了再挤太一了 太小了
Tasha: It's too small, squeeze it more. It's too small.
Alice:太小了
Alice: It's too small.
Alice: 好热呀你热不热薇薇
Alice: It's so hot, aren't you hot, Tasha?
Tasha: 还好
Tasha: It's alright.
Tasha: 就这么大就行
Tasha: This size is just fine.
Tasha: 平台上面没有显示
Tasha: It doesn't show on the platform.
Alice: 那怎么办你为什么不给我勾一个
Alice: What do we do then? Why didn't you check it for me?
Alice: 你要买现成的
Alice: You need to buy a ready-made one.
其它人: 那八辈子都能收到啊
其他人: 我估计我坐下来之后
其它人: 我都已经烧给你了
Alice: 行在你
Alice: Fine, it's up to you.
Alice: 我在你心里就只这一点点位置
Alice: I guess I only have a tiny spot in your heart.
Alice: 你不会为我学吗
Alice: Won't you learn for me?
Tasha: 挤死我得了我连拼图都不愿意拼的人你让我学那个
Tasha: It's killing me. I don't even like doing puzzles, and you want me to learn that?
Alice:好懂了
Alice: Alright, I get it.
Alice:我不在你心里面那么一点点的位置
Alice: I don't even have that little spot in your heart.
Jake: 差谁点一下吧
Jake: Can someone just press it?
Alice: 你用它测测你心里的温度吧
Alice: Why don't you measure the temperature of your heart with it?
Alice: 我觉得
Alice: I bet
Alice: 零下200度
Alice: It's minus 200 degrees.
其他人：零下18度
Others: Minus 18 degrees.
Tasha: 放可可
Tasha: Add some cocoa.
其他人：  还有PPT吗
Others: Any more PPTs?
Alice:啥
Alice: What?
Alice: 6啊你这眼睛是咋长的呀
Alice: Wow, your eyesight is amazing!
其他人：我眼睛就是尺
Others: My eyes are like a ruler.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yep.
Shure: 现在能不能吃了
Shure: Can we eat now?
Alice: 让你吃了 不知道呀
Alice: Not sure if you can eat it.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: Not sure.
Alice: 大馋丫头
Alice: You glutton!
其他人：你把我招到这儿你还怕我吃
Others: You invited me here and now you're worried I'll eat?
Alice:给你个原味儿的
Alice: Here, have a plain one.
Alice: 给
Alice: Take it.
Alice:快点
Alice: Hurry up.
Alice: 给你个原味的
Alice: Here's a plain one.
Alice:这只是味儿有点淡而已了
Alice: It just has a mild flavor.
Jake: 我们现在
Jake: We now...
其他人：这差不多应该算齐了
Others: This should be about right.
其他人： 有可能会到
Others: It might happen.
其他人：对她有可能来
Others: Yeah, she might come.
Jake: 哦这么 呵呵呵
Jake: Oh, really? Haha.
Jake:  好嘞好的没关系
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Jake: 那我们就
Jake: So we'll...
其他人：就因为理论上说就是就是
Others: Because theoretically, it's like...
其他人：  他今天应该会就是有时间应该会过来
Others: He should have time to come today.
其他人：不过他现在没跟我说
Others: But he hasn't told me yet.
其他人：刘婷: 那个妹子的话
Others: Liu Ting: That girl...
其他人：他因为太远了就不太方便
Others: It's too far for her, not convenient.
其他人： 如果他来的话就要来
Others: If she comes, she'll have to...
其他人： 两个小时左右然后回去还得回
Others: Spend about two hours here and two hours back.
其他人： 两个小时
Others: Two hours.
Lucia: 没有吗这不是很方便吗
Lucia: Isn't that pretty convenient?
其他人：啊一会儿你们把这些凳子要不都搬上去
Others: Hey, why don't you all move these chairs upstairs?
Jake: 哎你你来摆
Jake: Hey, you set it up.
Jake: 哈哈哈OK不是我们
Jake: Haha, OK, not us.
Jake: 我我们开开个场吧要不 往后摆 然后
Jake: Let's start, maybe set them further back and...
其他人：还是让他们坐比如坐垫子上
Others: Or let them sit on cushions.
Jake: 我想一想
Jake: Let me think.
Jake: 哎我想一想
Jake: 这边可能
Jake: Over here, maybe...
Jake: 这我们得都上去
Jake: We all need to go up there.
Jake: 那这个我们能上去搞
Jake: Can we go up and do this?
Jake: 吗对
Jake: Right?
Alice: 这个快这个快
Alice: This one is quick, this one is quick.
Alice: 弄好对了
Alice: Done, it's right.
其他人：要不搞完再上去
Jake:对 要不这一波
Jake: Yeah, or this round...
Jake: 这这这一波
Jake: This, this round...
Jake: 这波搞完
Jake: This round, we finish it.
Jake: 我上去
Jake: I'll go up.
Jake: 好行
Jake: Okay, got it.
Jake: 上去就介绍一下
Jake: I'll go up and give a brief intro.
Jake: 然后开场
Jake: Then start the event.
Jake: 呃到处每个房间走一走
Jake: Uh, walk around each room.
Jake: 装饰完了吗
Jake: Is the decoration done?
Jake: 那
Jake: So...
Jake: 好那就可以看是吧
Jake: Okay, then we can see it, right?
Jake: 还可以看
Jake: Still can see.
Jake: 那什么时候能出完全品
Jake: So when can we see the complete product?
Tasha: 不行
Tasha: No way.
Jake: 完全品
Jake: The complete product.
Jake: 完全的屋子
Jake: The complete house.
Jake: 完整状态
Jake: In perfect condition.
Alice: 这是原味
Alice: This is the original flavor.
其他人：不然它会掉
Others: Otherwise, it will fall off.
其他人：驴打滚
Others: "Rolling Donkey."
其他人：可以 哦压花
Others: Okay, oh, pressed flowers.
其他人：对对对你们去别的房间的时候
Others: Yeah, when you go to other rooms...
Alice:麻薯
Alice: Mochi.
其他人：c我就溜进去整理我的
Others: I'll just sneak in and tidy mine up.
Alice: 确实 应该 驴打滚的亲戚
Alice: Indeed, it's like a relative of "Rolling Donkey."
其他人： 对就是他这里还有两条腿
Others: Yeah, just that it has two more legs here.
Alice:还弄黄豆吗
Alice: Still adding soybeans?
Alice:有点少反正是
Alice: A bit less, anyway.
Alice:不过差不多
Alice:匀一点
Alice: Spread it evenly.
其他人：但这个有点小
Others: But this is a bit small.
其他人：不太好做
Others: Not easy to make.
Shure:  没关系个
Shure: It's okay.
其他人：  估计现在就能吃了
Others: I guess we can eat it now.
Alice: 这是熟的 蒸过的
Alice: This is cooked, it's steamed.
Alice: 怎么我还能毒死你啊毒死你也不会在这哎
Alice: How could I poison you? If I could, you wouldn't be here.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
其他人：真他妈上头你说什么
其他人：好下面    各位
Others: Okay, next up, everyone.
其他人：啊6个加3个垫子加一个多余的桌子
Others: Ah, 6 plus 3 cushions and an extra table.
Alice: 哈哈哈
其他人：啊这些凳子可以给它搬上去
Others: Ah, these stools can be moved up.
其他人：（歌声）你做了什么
Others: (singing) What did you do?
Jake: 这小这这小马
Jake: This little... this little pony...
Jake: 可以安上去么
Jake: Can it be installed?
Shure:  也可以VVVIP
Shure: It can also be a VVVVIP.
其他人：RIGHT RIGHT
Others: RIGHT RIGHT.
Jake: 好那就算了
Jake: Okay, forget it then.
Jake: 太重了是吧
Jake: It's too heavy, right?
Shure:  你就是night vip
Shure: You are just a night VIP.
Jake: 牛批哎呀
Jake: Awesome, wow.
Shure:  ego night好吧
Shure: Ego night, alright.
其他人：他是Ego house
Others: He is Ego house.
Shure:  他是Ego house
Shure: He is Ego house.
Shure:  你是Ego night
Shure: You are Ego night.
其他人：试图再整 出来一个
Others: Trying to come up with another one.
Alice: 你要吃哪个味刘婷
Alice: Which flavor do you want to eat, Liu Ting?
其他人:  都吃不起
Shure:  来来来给你俩照一张
Shure: Come on, let me take a picture of you two.
Alice: 不我要给你弄一些小的
Alice: No, I want to get you some small ones.
Shure:  你干什么不是你歧视
Shure: What are you doing? Aren't you being discriminatory?
Shure:  戴耳钉会怎么样吗
Shure: What's wrong with wearing earrings?
Alice: 我不爱吃可可
Alice: I don't like eating cocoa.
Shure:  你戴的是摇滚是吗哈哈
Shure: You are wearing rock style, right? Haha.
Alice: 我要整个形
Alice: I want to get a whole shape.
Alice: 爱心
Alice: Heart-shaped.
Shure:  怎么了
Shure: What's wrong?
Alice: 恶心啊
Alice: Disgusting.
Alice: 快
Alice: Quick.
其他人：这样不是真能吃了吧
Others: Isn't this really edible now?
Alice:真的这是熟的公主
Alice: Really, it's cooked, princess.
Shure:  没乐子看了是吗
Shure: No fun to watch anymore, huh?
其他人：说快说公主请吃
Others: Quickly say it, princess, please eat.
Alice: 公主你他妈赶紧去吃啊
Alice: Princess, just go eat, damn it.
其他人：不就是回去见家长吗
Others: Isn't it just meeting the parents?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 公主请吃
Alice: Princess, please eat
其他人：好嘞
Others: Okay
Alice: 这是耻辱
Alice: This is a disgrace
Alice: 萱哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：恩哇太好吃了
Others: Mmm, it's so delicious
Shure:  你非得要当一把大爷是吗
Shure: Do you really have to act like a big shot?
Shure:  啊不是
Shure: Oh, no
Lucia: 哈哈离炉子太近了
Lucia: Haha, too close to the stove
Shure:  嫂子开门
Shure: Open the door, sis-in-law
Alice:矿泉水矿泉水
Alice: Bottled water, bottled water
Shure:  我是我哥是吧
Shure: Is it my brother or me?
Alice: 就一点点
Alice: Just a little bit
Shure:  你给他加油
Shure: You cheer him on
Lucia: 转不出来了
Lucia: It won't turn
Lucia: 我的手机
Lucia: My phone
其他人：我以为吸不出来水了
Others: I thought it couldn't suck water anymore
Alice: 是不是水太少了
Alice: Is there too little water?
Lucia: 看起来还有半瓶
Lucia: Looks like there's still half a bottle
Alice: 你点他不管用哦
Alice: Pointing at it won't work
Alice: 那个啥他没插电吗不是
Alice: Is it not plugged in or what?
Tasha: 没插电
Tasha: Not plugged in
Alice: 你看那个那个那个那个
Alice: Look at that, look at that
Alice: 呃哪个不用啊
Alice: Uh, which one isn't working?
Tasha: 微波炉不用了
Tasha: The microwave's not working
Alice: 这个好像不用
Alice: This one doesn't seem to work
Alice: 这个你别拔错了这个烤鸭正在烤
Alice: Don't unplug the wrong one, the duck is roasting
Lucia: 对有一点点没事
Lucia: Yeah, a little bit is fine
其他人：那我觉得我可以不拔
Others: Then I think I don't need to unplug it
Lucia: 做饭还是很容易被烫到的
Lucia: Cooking can easily burn you
Alice: 要不你去其他地方把它挪走
Alice: Why don't you move it somewhere else?
其他人：二楼是不还有水
Others: Is there still water on the second floor?
Alice: 二楼也有
Alice: There's water on the second floor too
Tasha: 那个是正常的
Tasha: That's normal
Lucia: 等一下我擦下手然后给他回一下
Lucia: Wait, let me wipe my hands and then get back to him
Lucia: 呃是到哪里啊给他说
Lucia: Uh, where is it? Tell him
Shure:  在外面呢你打孔器
Shure: It's outside, you puncher
Shure:  咱早上不在外面能看见
Shure: We can't see it in the morning outside
Alice:薄脆
Alice: Crispy
其他人：这是个套餐吗
Others: Is this a set meal?
Alice:YES
Alice: YES
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Alice: 啊再拿一个吧
Alice: Ah, let's get another one.
Alice: 干什么you jump
Alice: What are you doing, you jump.
Alice: I jump了
Alice: I jumped.
Lucia: 我是那个朱利文建材
Lucia: I am from that Julian Construction Materials.
Lucia: 对四个都好一点是吧
Lucia: Yes, it's better to have all four, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 就是这个名字呢比较长
Lucia: It's just that the name is quite long.
Alice: 刘婷你愿意出多少钱买我的狗
Alice: Liu Ting, how much are you willing to pay for my dog?
其他人：什么你让我花钱
Others: What, you want me to pay?
Alice: 哈哈哈我的狗不值钱吗
Alice: Hahaha, is my dog not worth any money?
Alice: 在外边呢
Alice: It's outside.
Alice: 你能把它迎接回来吗
Alice: Can you bring it back?
Alice: 待会再迎接吧
Alice: Let's bring it back later.
Alice: 你愿意出多少买它
Alice: How much are you willing to pay for it?
其他人：会要我的命
Others: It will cost me my life.
其他人：你的心里人们是多少
Others: What's the price in your mind?
Alice:200
Alice: 200
其他人：能打12315吗
Others: Can I call 12315?
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Oh no.
Lucia: 没有口袋
Lucia: No pockets.
Alice:你那你那房间装饰好了吗
Alice: Have you decorated your room yet?
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Yes, it's done.
Lucia: 就就就这样吧
Lucia: Just like this.
Lucia: 管他呢反正好了
Lucia: Whatever, it's done.
Alice:就这样了
Alice: Just like that.
Alice: 你见过我的完整版吗
Alice: Have you seen my full version?
Lucia: 我可以看一下吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Alice: 啊你可以
Alice: Yes, you can.
Lucia: 啊谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Lucia: 我那个在大家去看之前我还得去粘一下
Lucia: Before everyone goes to see it, I need to fix it up.
Lucia: 因为美文纸
Lucia: Because the decorative paper.
Lucia: 特别容易掉
Lucia: Falls off easily.
Alice: 我掉了还没粘上呢
Alice: Mine fell off, I haven't fixed it yet.
Alice: 好的我去
Alice: Okay, I'll go.
Lucia: 那你去修整一下我和你一块去修整一下
Lucia: You go fix it, I'll come with you to fix it.
Alice: 我去补救一下
Alice: I'll go fix it up.
Tasha: 这怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia: 哇你的房间好香啊
Lucia: Wow, your room smells so good.
Lucia: 可惜还没有过来
Lucia: Too bad she hasn't come yet.
Alice: 拿个什么
Alice: What are you grabbing?
Alice: 那个水杯给我
Alice: Give me that cup.
其他人：这红豆
Others: These red beans.
Alice: 这是巧克力豆
Alice: These are chocolate beans.
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh...
Alice:比我命还硬
Alice: Tougher than my life.
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Forget it.
Alice: 哦 有一点碎的下面有
Alice: Oh, there's some broken pieces at the bottom.
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
其他人：干啥
Others: What?
Alice: 你吃巧克力吗
Alice: Do you eat chocolate?
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
其他人：我谢谢你姐
Others: Thank you, sis.
Alice: 好吃吗
Alice: Is it good?
其他人：OOK
Others: Okay.
Alice: 好吃这个都给你吃
Alice: If it's good, you can have all of it.
Alice: 这个反正用不上
Alice: We don't need it anyway.
Alice:给吧
Alice: Here.
Alice: 公主请吃
Alice: Princess, please eat.
其他人：别别别
Others: No, no, no.
其他人：给它放兜里放那个袋子里吧
Others: Put it in your pocket or in a bag.
Alice: 拿湿了没事
Alice: It's okay if it's wet.
Alice: 用不完用完了真疼啊
Alice: It hurts if you use it up.
其他人：谢谢姐谢谢
Others: Thanks, sis, thanks.
Alice: 怎么了呢
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha: 而且这个可以最后再拿
Tasha: And you can take this last.
Tasha: 就是一起拿
Tasha: Just take it all together.
Tasha: 蛋挞还没烤
Tasha: The egg tarts aren't baked yet.
Tasha: 还要半个小时就全部都做完了
Tasha: It'll take another half hour to finish everything.
Alice:ASMR
Alice: ASMR.
Alice: 嗯咋了
Alice: Hmm, what's up?
其他人：感觉侈有 根头发
Others: Feels like there's a hair.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 我们的抹茶粉
Alice: Our matcha powder.
Alice:当咚
Alice: Dang.
Alice:抹茶粉去哪里了
Alice: Where did the matcha powder go?
Alice:恩
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:抹茶粉在这里
Alice: The matcha powder is here.
Alice: 不要偷吃刘婷
Alice: Don't sneak a bite, Liu Ting.
Alice: 我指名点姓的提醒你
Alice: I'm specifically calling you out.
其他人：指名点姓的污蔑我 我去
Others: Accusing me by name, really?
Tasha: 不会吧
Tasha: No way.
Alice: 不会吧
Alice: No way.
Alice: 你不会偷吃吧
Alice: You wouldn't sneak a bite, right?
其他人：你是不被污鬼上身了
Others: Are you possessed by a ghost?
Alice: 不是本人
Alice: It's not me.
Alice: 刚刚好像有什么东西上我身了
Alice: I think something just possessed me.
Alice: 哈哈哈退退
Alice: Haha, go away, go away.
Alice: 退退退
Alice: Go away, go away.
Lucia: 开一下
Lucia: Open it.
Alice:我来开吧
Alice: I'll open it.
Lucia: 要几张
Lucia: How many?
Lucia: 两张
Lucia: Two.
Alice: 小心要往死里烫
Alice: Careful, it's extremely hot.
Tasha: 没事没事
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 别动别动
Lucia: Don't move, don't move.
其他人：你手机呢
Others: Where's your phone?
Alice: 你跟我在一块那么久
Alice: You've been with me for so long.
Alice: 你你不找我
Alice: And you didn't look for me?
Alice: 手机壳啥样
Alice: What does your phone case look like?
其他人：你的声音是从哪 儿传出来的不是我的吧哦我的
Others: Where's that voice coming from, not mine, oh it's mine.
Alice:你有
Alice: Do you have it?
Alice:爱情好像流沙
Alice: Love feels like quicksand.
Alice: 要不你去找我那挂纸给贴上
Alice: Why don't you go get my sticky note and put it on?
其他人：啊   先不着争处理那个
Others: Ah, let's deal with that later.
Alice: 咱俩这关系
Alice: Our relationship.
Alice: 如果提钱
Alice: If we mention money.
其他人：你刚才还说让我买你的狗呢
Others: You just asked me to buy your dog.
Shure:  所以我
Shure: So I...
Alice: 我那狗不值200吗
Alice: Isn't my dog worth 200?
其他人：我的劳动不值 200吗
Others: Isn't my labor worth 200?
Alice: 我就跟你说人民币我还没说刀呢真是我还没
Alice: I said RMB, not USD, really.
Alice: 我还没给你算别的品种呢
Alice: I haven't even calculated other breeds.
Alice: 我给你算人民币你还闲我黑
Alice: I quoted you in RMB and you think I'm overcharging.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
其他人：怎么能够假装一不小心栽到蛋糕上
Others: How can you pretend to accidentally fall into the cake?
Jake: 怎么样啊
Jake: How's it going?
Jake:哇哦
Jake: Wow
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Shure:  他可要走一大圈
Shure: He's going to take a big lap
Jake: 我来切
Jake: I'll cut it
Jake: 哈哈不理我
Jake: Haha, ignoring me
Jake: 对对对 算了算了算了算了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, forget it, forget it, forget it
Alice: 真嘟假嘟
Alice: Really or not?
Alice: 你知道怎么挂吗
Alice: Do you know how to hang it?
Alice: 那你就这么自信的走过去
Alice: You just walk over with such confidence
Alice: 你再给我装饰
Alice: Then you decorate it for me
Alice: 破坏了 美景破坏了
Alice: Ruined, the view is ruined
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 咱还是不毁了
Jake: Let's not ruin it
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  可以
Shure: Okay
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello
Alice: 哈喽你用那个纸
Alice: Hello, use that paper
其他人：啊那不是浊贴了个胶啊这个
Others: Ah, didn't you just put tape on it?
Shure:  老板你好你好
Shure: Boss, hello, hello
Alice: 是用这个哎
Alice: Use this one
Alice: 你把它打开一下
Alice: Open it up
其他人：哎呀
Others: Oh no
Alice:这儿呢
Alice: Here it is
Shure:  这呢哎呀
Shure: Here it is, oh no
其他人：哎呀啊
Others: Oh no, ah
其他人：你这个箱子
Others: This box of yours
Alice:这个这个这个胶哦
Alice: This, this, this tape, oh
Alice: 正好我的那个充电器你可以用
Alice: My charger fits perfectly
Alice:然后你就这样贴吧
Alice: Then you just stick it like this
Lucia: 然后你就这样帮找借口给他
Lucia: Then you just make excuses for him
Alice:GET UP
Alice: GET UP
其他人：你给我摘了我给你拿点
Others: You take it off, I'll get you something
Alice: 我这玩意给你
Alice: I'll give you this thing
其他人：你这个箱子不是也是配合这个蹦极吧
Others: Isn't your box also for bungee jumping?
Alice: 你放屁我多长时间之前买的
Alice: You're talking nonsense, I bought it a long time ago
Alice: 你看我这不艺术吗
Alice: Doesn't this look artistic?
Alice: 我这挂着花呢哎我的天
Alice: I hung flowers here, oh my god
Alice: 哎老是那个味的
Alice: It's always that smell
Alice: 哎呀这个真他妈的难贴
Alice: Ah, this is so damn hard to stick on.
Alice: 不好意思
Alice: Sorry.
Alice: 正在录着
Alice: We're recording.
Alice: 不应该说脏话
Alice: I shouldn't swear.
Alice:低调
Alice: Keep it low-key.
Alice:爱情
Alice: Love.
Alice: 像流沙哎
Alice: It's like quicksand.
Alice: 刘啥意思就是刘婷那个傻子
Alice: Liu, what does that mean, that fool Liu Ting.
Alice: 别走
Alice: Don't go.
Alice: 为什么要走
Alice: Why are you leaving?
Alice: 别走应该应该不能这样
Alice: Don't go, you shouldn't.
其他人：你出言不讯哪 你
Others: You speak without manners.
其他人：大逆不道 造反天罡
Others: Such rebellion, defying the heavens.
Alice: 真嘟假嘟
Alice: Really?
Alice: 好妈的我直接贴一条
Alice: Fine, I'll just stick one on.
其他人：你跟这儿过过了几天把你逼 疯了吧
Others: You've been here for a few days and it's driving you crazy, huh?
Alice: 我想你想的发疯了
Alice: I'm going crazy thinking about you.
Alice: 为什么不让我在你家玩
Alice: Why won't you let me hang out at your place?
其他人： 那是另外的价钱
Others: That costs extra.
Alice: 多少钱我出的起
Alice: How much? I can afford it.
其他人：200
Others: 200.
Alice:我考
Alice: Damn.
其他人：dollar
Others: Dollars.
Alice: 那我直接拿
Alice: Then I'll just take it.
Alice: 拿着狗去你家不就正好了吗
Alice: Taking the dog to your place is perfect, right?
Alice:啊不是吗
Alice: Isn't it?
Alice: 我直接 拿着狗去你家
Alice: I'll just take the dog to your place.
Alice: 行吧这再掉
Alice: Okay, if it falls again...
Alice: 再掉我他妈
Alice: If it falls again, damn it...
Alice: 没事好
Alice: It's okay.
Alice: 这小床铺的我中午都没午睡
Alice: This little bed, I didn't even get a nap at noon.
Alice: 香不香
Alice: Smells good?
Alice: 哦开空调了好热啊
Alice: Oh, the air conditioning is on, it's so hot.
Alice:薄荷
Alice: Mint.
Alice: 香
Alice:我们不是买了那个半半好多呢
Alice: Didn't we buy a lot of that half-half thing?
Alice:萱
Alice: Xuan.
Alice: 无妨
Alice: No problem.
其他人：好吃就行
Others: As long as it tastes good.
Alice:不可以吃
Alice: You can't eat that.
Alice: 洗了吗洗了吗
Alice: Did you wash it? Did you wash it?
Alice:这个洗过就可以吃
Alice: You can eat it after washing.
Alice: 巧克力豆嘛
Alice: Chocolate chips, right?
其他人：那那那那
Others: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 这种事在我们这经常不发
Tasha: This kind of thing happens a lot with us.
其他人：哎你们这个项目经费都是报销的对吗
Others: Hey, you guys get reimbursed for all your project expenses, right?
Alice: 你想给我们捐点吗
Alice: Do you want to donate some to us?
Alice: 你来报销
Alice: You can reimburse us.
其他人：我是想存我是想黑点
Others: I just want to save up, I want to skim some off.
Alice: 这话是可以说的吗
Alice: Can you say that?
其他人：抽一点哈哈哈
Others: Just a little bit, hahaha.
Alice: 你为啥
Alice: Why?
其他人：多拿点莱克和走
Others: Take more and leave.
Alice: 你这都快贴脸上了的睫毛你知道
Alice: Your eyelashes are almost sticking to your face, you know.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 鲜
Alice: Fresh.
其他人：真是一个比较有要求的一个小女孩
Others: She's quite a demanding little girl.
Alice:那必须
Alice: Absolutely.
Alice:像像
Alice: Yeah, yeah.
Alice: 你别再发出那种魔性的声音了
Alice: Stop making that weird sound.
Alice:好吗
Alice: Okay?
Alice: 我跟你说啊
Alice: Let me tell you.
Alice: 你万一发生了像那天的事
Alice: If something like that happens again...
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Alice: 我跟你说你
Alice: I'm telling you...
Alice: 今年你就得内向了你知道吗
Alice: This year you'll become an introvert, you know?
Alice: 一次
Alice: Once.
其他人：不会吧哈哈哈
Others: No way, hahaha.
Alice: 你有哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: You will, hahaha.
其他人：我的故事还有这一个呢
Others: I have another story like that.
Alice: 会重蹈覆辙的我跟你说
Alice: You'll repeat the same mistakes, I'm telling you.
Alice: 我只能这么告诉你
Alice: That's all I can tell you.
其他人：好哈哈哈
Others: Okay, hahaha.
Alice:呖哈哈哈怎么不唱了哈哈哈
Alice: Why did you stop singing? Hahaha.
Alice: 怎么不唱了
Alice: Why did you stop?
其他人：（歌声）三颗心三颗心我们讨厌你
Others: (Singing) Three hearts, three hearts, we hate you.
Alice: 你想进去啊
Alice: You want to go in?
Alice: 哦sorry
Alice: Oh, sorry.
Alice: 我给你洗个草莓怎么样 下一个
Alice: How about I wash a strawberry for you? Next one.
Alice: no栓Q
Alice: No, thank you.
Alice: 洗俩 一人一个 真好 谢冰
Alice: I'll wash two, one for each of us. Great, thanks Bing.
Alice:给
Alice: Here you go.
其他人：狼在对如狗在吼
Others: The wolf howls like a dog.
Lucia: 但我看他们给我发
Lucia: But I saw them send it to me.
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha.
其他人：你要是不跟我说还好
Others: It would have been better if you hadn't told me.
其他人：现在我完全警惕自己
Others: Now I'm completely on guard.
Alice: 你现在怎么变内向了
Alice: How did you become so introverted now?
Alice: 刘婷你不是挺爱说话的吗
Alice: Liu Ting, weren't you quite talkative?
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:我去
Shure:  太棒了
Jake: Oh my.
Jake: 这个留着让大伙一起挤
Jake: Let's save this for everyone to squeeze together.
Jake: 就是这个奶油的
Jake: It's the cream.
Alice:上面奶油
Alice: The cream on top.
Jake: 奶油大伙可以自己挤
Jake: Everyone can squeeze the cream themselves.
Alice:奶油还没打呢
Alice: The cream isn't whipped yet.
Tasha: 还没挤还没打人家说蛋挞里一起打
Tasha: It's not squeezed or whipped yet, they said to whip it together with the egg tart.
Alice: 怎么内向
Alice: How are you so introverted?
Alice: 不唱了 怎么这么摇滚
Alice: Not singing anymore? Why so rock and roll?
Alice: 我记得你唱歌挺好听的呀
Alice: I remember you used to sing pretty well.
其他人：我天生不爱唱
Others: I was born not to love singing.
Alice: 没事那个人好像不在
Alice: It's okay, that person doesn't seem to be here.
Alice: 他在二楼
Alice: He's on the second floor.
Alice: 你可以吃瓜子
Alice: You can eat sunflower seeds.
Alice: 你吃瓜子吗
Alice: Do you eat sunflower seeds?
Alice:坐会儿吧累的
Alice: Sit down for a bit, you must be tired.
Alice:三天三夜
Alice: Three days and three nights.
Alice: 咋晚上有约了
Alice: Do you have plans tonight?
Alice: 约谁了
Alice: Who are you meeting?
Alice: 跟我玩
Alice: Play with me.
Alice: 还搞时间规划
Alice: Still making time schedules.
Alice: 跟谁约
Alice: Who are you meeting?
Alice:恩差不多
Alice: Yeah, pretty much.
Alice:啊朋友再见
Alice: Ah, goodbye friends.
Jake: 要帮忙吗
Jake: Need help?
Jake: 我靠这怎么这个样子
Jake: Wow, why is it like this?
Alice: 筛过可可粉
Alice: Sifted cocoa powder.
Alice:油纸
Alice: Parchment paper
Alice: 婷
Alice: Ting
Tasha: 这两个都铺一下
Tasha: Lay these two out
Alice: give me 油纸
Alice: Give me the parchment paper
其他人：我以为你说的
Others: I thought you said...
Alice: 我说
Alice: I said...
Alice: 我说你你低智
Alice: I said you're stupid
Alice:爱情
Alice: Love
Alice: 有活采
Alice: Alive color
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
其他人： 他那个后来画设计图的时候我就看到了
Others: I saw it when he was drawing the design later
其他人：不是姐们你还设计呢
Others: Seriously, girl, you’re still designing?
Alice: 咋了
Alice: What's up?
Alice: 这戒指是我设计的呀
Alice: I designed this ring
Jake: 来把修硕给弄上了
Jake: Come on, get Shure involved
Alice:啊 跟姐妹待这长时间
Alice: Ah, spent so much time with the girls
Jake: 修硕
Jake: Shure
Alice: 都不知道 什么意思
Alice: Don't even know what it means
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
Alice: 你外面有狗了
Alice: You have a dog outside
Alice: 我们不好了刘婷
Alice: We’re done, Liu Ting
Alice: 刀不知道剪刀在哪
Alice: I don't know where the scissors are
Alice: 虽然有这个
Alice: Even though there's this
Alice: 但我没看见
Alice: But I haven't seen it
Alice: 给你表演一个丝滑
Alice: Let me show you something smooth
Alice: 撕这个好吗
Alice: Tear this, okay?
Alice: 如果不丝滑就是愿意看
Alice: If it's not smooth, just keep watching
Alice: 你影响了观测
Alice: You’re affecting the observation
Alice: 撕太长啦
Alice: Tore it too long
Alice: 真嘟假嘟
Alice: Really fake
Alice:不行我得给它剪点上剪刀
Alice: No, I need to cut it with scissors
其他人：前刀比贴纸还难找
Others: It's harder to find the front knife than the stickers
Alice: 我也那么觉得
Alice: I think so too
Alice: 我们这可缺剪刀了
Alice: We really lack scissors here
Alice: 算了这样剪吧吧
Alice: Forget it, let's cut it like this
Lucia: 嗯好的好的
Lucia: Hmm, okay, okay
Jake: 然后一楼
Jake: Then the first floor
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right
Alice: 你慎言我跟你说
Alice: Watch your words, I'm telling you
Alice: 那人家设计的那啥
Alice: That person designed that thing
Alice: 你怎么老干那种事啊
Alice: Why do you always do that?
其他人：你主这个是设计的这个是设计的
Others: This is the design, this is the design.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
其他人：那其实从设计角度上来说它还是蛮错的
Others: Actually, from a design perspective, it's quite wrong.
其他人： 相地于就是买到的这个商用的
Others: It's like the commercial one you bought.
Alice: 我看你啊
Alice: I see you.
Alice: 你是
Alice: You are...
Alice: 拖鞋一点记性不长刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting, you never learn, huh?
Alice: 你说今天晚上我真的有有法
Alice: You know, tonight I really have something to say.
Alice: 又有得聊了咱 俩
Alice: We'll have a good chat, the two of us.
其他人：这设计设计 的是什么是树枝
Others: What's this design? Is it branches?
其他人：蜘蛛
Others: A spider?
Alice:鸟
Alice: A bird.
其他人：你也设计一个
Others: You design one too.
其他人：没看出来我以为是冬天那种光秃秃的树干
Others: I couldn't tell, I thought it was bare winter branches.
Alice:嗨就这样吧
Alice: Oh well, it is what it is.
Alice:哎哟我操
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice: 你也上去吧
Alice: You go up too.
Alice: 带着我
Alice: Take me with you.
其他人：啊干嘛去啊
Others: Where are we going?
Alice: 上楼
Alice: Upstairs.
Alice: 找个地坐
Alice: Find a place to sit.
Alice:不用
Alice: No need.
Alice: 这先搁那没地儿啊
Alice: Just put it there, no space, huh?
Alice: 你截过边还很大吗
Alice: Did you cut the edge? Is it still big?
Alice: 有剪刀没啊
Alice: Do we have scissors?
Alice: 扎死了
Alice: It's poking me.
Alice: 直接剪吧
Alice: Just cut it.
Alice: 那个太不好用了
Alice: That one's too hard to use.
其他人：哇你现在跟我说这个东西
Others: Wow, now you're telling me this?
Alice:萱
Alice: Xuan.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:拿着
Alice: Take it.
Alice: 那刘婷顾头不顾腚
Alice: Liu Ting, you only focus on the head, not the tail.
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Alice: 哦 你给他拿上去顺便骂他一下
Alice: Oh, you take it up and scold her a bit too.
Alice: 说她顾头不顾腚
Alice: Tell her she only focuses on the head, not the tail.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Alice: 这个小不小
Alice: Is this small?
Alice: 就是这个边的
Alice: Just this edge.
Alice: 好满足
Alice: So satisfied
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh
Alice: 因为你朋友来吗
Alice: Because your friend is coming?
Alice: 可以吗
Alice: Is it okay?
Alice: 虽然有点不规则
Alice: Even though it's a bit irregular
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's just go with this
Alice: 这个菱形这样吧
Alice: How about this diamond shape?
Tasha: 洗个那个锅铲行吗
Tasha: Can you wash that spatula?
Tasha: 就是那个硅胶铲
Tasha: The silicone one
Shure:  让AI看看害羞的人类是么
Shure: Let AI see the shy human, right?
Tasha: 在哪里呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Tasha: 床是干的
Tasha: The bed is dry
Tasha: 然后再拿个裱花袋在冰箱上
Tasha: Then get a piping bag from the fridge
Tasha: 嗯把草莓洗一下和蓝莓
Tasha: Hmm, wash the strawberries and blueberries
Tasha: 就放在这就行
Tasha: Just put them here, it's fine
Tasha: 草莓和蓝莓
Tasha: Strawberries and blueberries
Tasha: 各洗一盒吧
Tasha: Wash a box of each
Tasha: 呃不够还有一盒嘞
Tasha: Uh, not enough, there's another box
Alice:嗨
Alice: Hi
Alice: 需要我做什么
Alice: Do you need me to do anything?
Jake: 好那我们这边就
Jake: Alright, then we'll
Jake: 算了可以开始
Jake: Forget it, we can start
Alice: 还还需要
Alice: Still need
Jake: 还需要
Jake: Still need
Alice: 挤奶油
Alice: 然后
Alice: Then
Jake: 挤奶油挤奶油挤奶油  要不就
Jake: 挤奶油大概要多久啊
Jake: How long does it take to whip the cream?
Jake: 还是说可以把它冻起来
Jake: Or can we just freeze it?
Alice: 什么冻起来
Alice: Freeze it?
Jake: 就放冰箱冻起来给他们一起挤
Jake: Just put it in the freezer so they can whip it together
Alice: 薇薇你还好吗感觉你好累休息好了吗
Alice: Tasha, are you okay? You look so tired, did you rest well?
Alice: 你的朋友到了吗
Alice: Has your friend arrived?
Alice: 现在现在人齐了吗
Alice: Is everyone here now?
Jake:剪刀
Jake: Scissors
Jake: 可能要帮师傅翻一下
Jake: Might need to help the chef flip it
Alice: 小吗这个口
Alice: Is this opening too small?
Tasha: 不小挤吧
Tasha: It's not small, just squeeze
Alice: 我挤的挺丑的
Alice: My squeezing is pretty ugly
Alice: 我可以挤平面吗
Alice: Can I do it flat?
Tasha: 切半
Tasha: Cut it in half.
Tasha: 要不你把蛋糕这个切一下行吗
Tasha: Can you cut the cake a bit?
Alice: 切一下切成两半吗
Alice: Cut it in half?
ihat1:有的要切对半
ihat1: Some need to be cut in half.
Alice: 都切两半
Alice: Cut them all in half.
Tasha: 有一半切对半就行了
Tasha: Just cut one half in half.
Alice: 找个刀
Alice: Get a knife.
Alice: 刀在这吗
Alice: Is the knife here?
Alice: 我们的案板呢
Alice: Where's our cutting board?
其他人：这个吗
Others: This one?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Alice: : 干净的吗
Alice: Is it clean?
其他人：应该 或计大概也许
Others: Probably, or maybe.
Alice: 涮一下吧
Alice: Rinse it a bit.
Jake:欧欧欧
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice:嗨 哎哟没事吧
Alice: Hey, are you okay?
Alice:我挤吧
Alice: I'll squeeze it.
Jake:好你们挤完就OK
Jake: Alright, once you finish squeezing it, it's all good.
Alice:拿上去
Alice: Lift it up.
Jake: 拿倒了哎哟我去拿到哪儿去
Jake: It's upside down! Oh no, where are you taking it?
Lucia: 这个那个哪个
Lucia: This one, that one, which one?
Lucia: 上面的那个吗
Lucia: The one on top?
Jake:这个我们是在这儿摆盘是吗
Jake: Are we plating it here?
Lucia: 那边没有电子产品吗
Lucia: Are there no electronics over there?
Jake:那边没有
Jake: None over there.
Shure:  大家知道今天是什么日子吗
Shure: Do you all know what day it is today?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 你们你们要不暖场
Jake: Either you warm up the crowd,
Jake: 要不下来干活
Jake: or get down to work.
Jake: 不能坐着知道不
Jake: You can't just sit there, got it?
Jake: 所谓剧组成员
Jake: We're a crew, after all.
Alice: 咋了
Alice: What’s up?
Alice: 收拾
Alice: Clean up.
Jake:收拾然后把这收掉
Jake: Clean up and clear this away.
其他人：这个晚上还要装起来吗
Others: Do we need to set this up again tonight?
Jake:现马上就要蒸呗
Jake: No, we're steaming it now.
Tasha: 不这两个就只有这个小房子不要
Tasha: No, just don’t need this little house.
Jake: 刘帅呢
Jake: Where's Choiszt?
Jake: 董叉叉呢
Jake: Where's Jack?
Jake:  干嘛呢
Jake: What are they doing?
Jake: 哈哈 他们他们在暖吗
Jake: Haha, are they warming up?
Jake:呵maybe
Jake: Heh, maybe
其他人：这个要吗
Others: Do we need this?
Alice: 不要
Alice: No
其他人：都不要了
Others: We don't need it
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
其他人：搁这了
Others: Put it here
Alice: 秘诀
Alice: Secret
其他人：又偷一本武林秘籍
Others: Stole another martial arts secret book
Jake: 唉我去放在这边擦干的是不
Jake: Hey, did I leave it here to dry?
Alice: 是不是饮料洒了
Alice: Did someone spill a drink?
Alice: 怎么闻见一股果汁味呢
Alice: Why do I smell juice?
Lucia: 是
Lucia: Yes
Lucia: 刚才有一瓶那个
Lucia: There was a bottle just now
其他人：葡萄汁
Others: Grape juice
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one
Lucia: 这是谁的
Lucia: Whose is this?
Alice: 你咋不在上面呢
Alice: Why aren't you upstairs?
Shure:  给大家放一点这个和节日这个相关的这种
Shure: I'll put on something related to the holiday for everyone
其他人：我来上卫生间
Others: I'm going to the bathroom
Alice: 卫生间那儿呢那上面也有卫生间
Alice: There's a bathroom upstairs too
Lucia: 没事你都下来了就去吧
Lucia: It's fine, since you're down, just go
其他人：来吧来吧
Others: Go ahead, go ahead
Jake: 还有啥这个要洗掉对吧
Jake: What else needs to be washed, right?
Alice:YES
Alice: YES
Jake: 为什么现在有手套了
Jake: Why do we have gloves now?
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What's up?
Alice: 因为刚来的
Alice: Because they just arrived
Alice: 这要不补一点
Alice: Should we add a bit more?
Jake: 这个要丢掉是吧
Jake: This needs to be thrown away, right?
Jake: 这个这个肯定是空的
Jake: This is definitely empty
Jake: 这些该放哪啊
Jake: Where should these go?
Tasha: 这这8个都放在这个托盘上
Tasha: Put these 8 on this tray
Tasha: 都放在那个小架子上
Tasha: All on that little shelf
Alice: 那个架子脏脏的
Alice: That shelf is dirty
Tasha: 那就放托盘上
Tasha: Then put them on the tray
Jake: 架子脏脏的就垫一下吧
Jake: If the shelf is dirty, just put something under it
Alice: 托盘吧
Alice: Use the tray
Jake: 这个这个纸
Jake: This, this paper
Lucia: 纸在
Lucia: The paper is here
Alice: 纸在这
Alice: The paper is here.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
其他人：哇来个麦旋风吧
Others: Wow, let's get a McFlurry.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 对你的麦旋风
Alice: Here's your McFlurry.
Jake: 我买的麦旋风
Jake: I bought the McFlurry.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing?
Jake: 垫垫一下吗
Jake: Just padding it.
其他人：现在怎样拿上去吗
Others: Should we put it up now?
Tasha: 剪很窄就行了
Tasha: Just cut it narrow, that'll be fine.
Alice: 等吧
Alice: Let's wait.
Jake: 这个放在这吧
Jake: Let's put this here.
Tasha:  剪跟他 还有3分钟
Tasha: Cut it, there's still 3 minutes.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 好  还有三分钟啥
Alice: Alright, three minutes for what?
Jake: 4点开始
Jake: Start at 4 o'clock.
Alice: 在那在那
Alice: There, over there.
Jake: 剪刀
Jake: Scissors.
Jake: 有点
Jake: Got it.
Alice: 这个不好使反正
Alice: This one isn't working well anyway.
Alice:无妨
Alice: No worries.
Lucia: 因为那个剪刀
Lucia: Because those scissors...
Lucia: 刚才好像不是用来剪快递的吗
Lucia: Weren't those used for cutting packages earlier?
Alice: 啊我已经用来剪它了无所谓了
Alice: Ah, I've already used them to cut this, it's fine.
Lucia:  也没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Jake: 没听见没听见
Jake: Didn't hear that, didn't hear that.
Lucia: 嗯确实
Lucia: Yeah, indeed.
Lucia: 拜拜
Lucia: Bye-bye.
Lucia: 这里面有一个那个啥的印
Lucia: There's a mark inside here.
Lucia: 那也够吧
Lucia: That's enough, right?
Lucia: 那是沿着撕缝的
Lucia: It's along the tear line.
Jake: 我们这个摆在上面么
Jake: Should we place this on top?
Jake: 海是摆在下面了
Jake: Or place it underneath?
Tasha: 这条会不有点窄
Tasha: Isn't this strip a bit narrow?
Lucia: 好像还行 但是会长出来一点点
Lucia: Seems fine, but it might stick out a little.
Alice: 剪了吧剪了
Alice: Just cut it, cut it.
Alice: 你折一下然后我剪
Alice: You fold it, then I'll cut.
Alice: 按照你的痕迹剪
Alice: Cut along your crease.
Lucia: 它大概长出来这么多
Lucia: It'll probably stick out this much.
Jake: 剪一下剪一下
Jake: Cut it, cut it.
Alice: 在底下呢 底下呢
Alice: It's below, it's below
Jake: 那底下呢
Jake: What's below?
Lucia: 感觉这样也行
Lucia: I think this works too
Alice: 你给我捏捏肩膀好吗
Alice: Can you massage my shoulders?
其他人：另外的价格
Others: Different price
Alice:哎哟上去吧上去吧
Alice: Oh well, just go on, go on
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha
Alice:恩
Alice: Hmm
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay
Jake:来水
Jake: Bring water
Jake: 我们上去喷喷水
Jake: We'll spray some water up there
Jake: 这个就往上面摆了
Jake: Just put it up there
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 请大家先喝点矿泉水
Lucia: Everyone, please have some mineral water first
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Alice: 那个太长了
Alice: That one's too long
Alice: 就光底下那个底就行了
Alice: Just the bottom part is enough
Lucia: 好好看啊
Lucia: It looks really good
Alice: 无妨
Alice: No problem
Lucia: 底下是不是还需要一条
Lucia: Does the bottom need another one?
Jake: 一会儿 我们端上去吗
Jake: Should we carry it up later?
Alice: 在上面还是在下边
Alice: Up or down?
Jake: 端上去吧下面
Jake: Carry it up, to the bottom
Alice: 没没啥了就等着
Alice: There's nothing more, just waiting now
其他人：这两个都是新的吧
Others: Are both of these new?
Alice:哪个
Alice: Which one?
其他人：麦旋风
Others: McFlurry
Alice: 地 一个是杨老板的
Alice: One is Jake's
Alice: 有一个是
Alice: One is
Alice: 另外一个不知道
Alice: I don't know the other one
其他人：这有预订 吗
Others: Is this one pre-ordered?
Alice:没有
Alice: No
其他人：新的
Others: It's new
Alice:因为昨天这是画的
Alice: Because this was painted yesterday
Tasha: 这个怎么没拿着啊
Tasha: Why didn't you take this?
Tasha: 还有4个呢
Tasha: There are four more
Alice: 这呢这这这
Alice: Here, here, here
Jake: 你是客人是吧
Jake: Are you a guest?
Alice: 往上摆吧
Alice: Put it up
Alice:那上面呢
Alice: What about the top?